what's going on guys this is rob and i
am excited why am i excited because we
have crossed a hundred thousand
subscribers kind of but not really
technically we're at 98 300 but we're
going to cross 100k here in the next
couple weeks so it is inevitable and i
you guys know how i get when i get
excited right i just love making videos
where i get to celebrate stuff so i want
to celebrate 100 000 subscribers early
hopefully we don't lose subs
watch me upload this video and then two
days later we lose like 10 000
subscribers like no you know what screw
rob i'm gonna make sure he doesn't get
to 100k so i'm gonna unsubscribe
i hope that doesn't happen but
nonetheless i'm really excited about
that so on behalf of my staff and my
staff is very very important my staff
isn't here really like i'm in my
basement one day i'll give you guys a
tour of the whole studio because it's
literally
a canon c200 an mkh416 microphone two
aperture 120d light domes and some sound
treatment and that's it in my
workstation right over there and that's
it that's all this here in the basement
my editor alex is in florida my social
media guy tony who you guys know is tc
dust comics he's in california my main
scriptwriter ryan is down in kentucky
and my database manager mike is in
kentucky so we're kind of all over the
place truth to tell
we're not really in a consolidated
location i feel like we should be at
some point in time but we're still a
pretty small operation so at the moment
we can get away with this but this
channel would not be as successful as it
is one in part to you guys and two in
part to my staff and having said that
one of the things that we've noticed
looking through the comments because we
do read your comments we love to hear
what it is you guys have to say a lot of
you all are asking for content that's
not strictly related to the marvel
cinematic universe tv shows and movies
things like that and that's totally
understandable we do have a little bit
of variety in so far as like the rumor
roundup but even then because of the
fact that they're well really the
playstation announcement just dumped a
ton of stuff but with the exception of
that there's not a ton of news coming
out with regards to those things that
seems highly topical relative to the
stuff that we're talking about here so
one of the things that we were looking
at is the things that you guys are
requesting kind of expanding that out
and seeing what you all are interested
in now a lot of you guys who have been
around this since the beginning we were
experimenting with different topics and
ideas right the truth is it was a little
too early to experiment with that right
just because we didn't really have the
audience size for it speaking of which i
know a lot of you guys are trying to
become full-time youtubers you want to
become a full-time youtuber you see all
these videos on youtube where they
explain how to grow over the course of
half an hour i'll explain to you how to
grow on youtube in 10 seconds check this
out make your videos longer than 10
minutes get people to watch as much of
your video as you possibly can that's
called audience retention and then
upload at least three times a week to
maximize your watch time and that's how
you grow on youtube done having said
that we were we were really kind of
trying to go in the right direction but
just sort of doing it at the wrong time
we didn't have the audience we weren't
really in the youtube algorithm so our
videos weren't really being circulated
around but this point right here is what
we call a branch off period this is a
point in your youtube channel when you
start looking at the process of
branching out and doing different things
and so one of the things that i'm
kicking around here is the idea of the
anime review club this is basically a
concept that i've been talking about for
months on this channel where we
basically have a kind of talking head
discussion or possibly only a couple
people maybe just one person but
basically this sort of talking head
format that i do when i'm doing like
origins and powers or any normal video
that you see here on this channel but
something about anime right something
that has to do with anime and or manga
but we can also do the same thing with
video games so here's what i want from
you guys here's what i'm looking for
from you guys i know it's gonna be the
vocal minority that's fine those of you
guys who are looking for a particular
type of content related to the geek
culture brand right we're not going to
do anything that talks about politics so
don't ask but if you guys are interested
in seeing content in this fear of geek
culture anime manga video games tech
stuff like that let us know for the most
part we want to kind of branch out from
the the really marvel cinematic universe
whatever passes for the dc cinematic
universe kind of thing and sort of
branch out from there so it'll be
somewhat of a slow progression anime
would be the closest choice but those
are guys who want to see stuff post it
down in the comments let us know in the
comments what kind of content you're
interested in seeing and then we'll go
from there because i'm going to tell you
guys right now one of the things that
i'm kind of kicking around here is
actually hiring somebody bringing
somebody in maybe not necessarily here
but somebody somewhere and have them and
basically hire them to do the anime
stuff right because i'm not an expert on
anime and manga and i feel like if we're
gonna do that here on this channel i
want to bring in somebody who is an
expert on that kind of thing which
really begs the question do any of you
guys know anyone with a good camera and
a good microphone who has good screen
presence
like moi
who is very knowledgeable about anime
and manga
do you guys know anybody like that if
you do post a comment down below or post
their name down below or tag me on
twitter whatever the case is but let me
know right i'm really excited to see if
we can't possibly bring some people on
board hire somebody or something along
those lines but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for being part of this
journey here on geek culture explained
it's very exciting i'd love to see this
whole thing is growing thank you guys
for being a part of this and i will
catch you all later
peace